so today we're going to show a game
that's way above the heads of the class
because well what's face and everything
is but maybe you at home can understand
this is the game played a few days ago
between the Chinese champion Wei Yi only
16 years old and one of the top five
players in Cuba bruised on some say
bruise on Batista but I don't I say
bruise on okay and this is a famous game
and if you're Ronan Harvey and you're
watching this video just turn it off
because your puny brain can understand
what's going on here okay
so this is considered the game of the
century all the centuries only 15 16
years old right so maybe 15 2000 ones
the first year of the century so in the
fifteenth year of the century anyway
waggy sacrificed all of his pieces which
usually is bad and then his opponent
King walked up the board and got
checkmated which is good if you're the
one checkmating and this was my favorite
game of the year irrespective of Ronan
Harvey's crazy comments so let's have a
look they started out with my favorite
Sicilian efore c5 and white played a
very strange move order he played nine
c3 and Bishop e2 and this sort of
confused black so they actually
transpose it to another variation the
same in ingen as they say in Holland
which is actually a resort town vacation
city and black aventure just played d6
and this position has occurred thousands
of times
except bruise on who plays the Sicilian
with Black has only had this position
once and he was sort of tricked into it
by a move order but that's neither here
nor there okay and this is all many many
many Grandmaster games not that I know
them okay and usually we get a decisive
result which means somebody wins because
why it's playing from
eight by moving his arms like Donkey
Kong somehow and black is saying dude
I'm very solid if you push all your
stuff I'm just going to take it all and
actually both happened so everybody was
happy
especially the audience Queen da and
this has all been played before
even though supposedly bruise on didn't
know the opening very well okay so
bruise on is ready for a five why it's
not going to play e5 because then the
Queen and rook will give the beatdown on
the D file so he played Queen aged three
possibly he's going to push here
possibly he's going to play e5 anyway
and play for checkmate
so g6 no more checkmate and that's a key
idea the Sicilian is they get checkmated
on h7 it's an idea for black getting
checkmated and it's idea for white
checkmating his opponent most people
don't like to get checkmated so black
played g6 and block the bishop and then
White has something to attack now so he
played half five and attacked it and
black played a five because as you will
notice this pawn is attacked too many
times right so we gotta get that pawn
out of the way attacking the bishop pawn
takes pawn
Oh Bishop e3 us play I took the pawn
rikiei and he takes the pawn alright now
we're going to vote and it's going to be
a small vote here we got three people
over here you can vote at home if you
want will tabulate the results later
much later would you take with H pawn or
would you take with F pawn let's vote
ready to vote you thinking about it
alright who would take with the H pawn
raise your hand okay and who would take
with the F pawn three to zero now your
kids in some class for four nights and
this guy is a strong Grandmaster do you
think you guys would agree that's too
complicated question for him the guy who
is playing black is a Grandmaster much
stronger than me
and your three kids sitting in a class
do you think you three kids will agree
with the Grandmaster you think the move
you decided that's the move that he
playing think again hhg you take towards
the center or are okay and your moves
not bad F takes G but generally you want
everything towards the center also white
can't sacrifice his rook for a pawn if
you play F G that makes again what's
interesting okay so now I have some
people I know I used to call them
friends now they're just dumb people
right you know what I'm talking about
yeah thank you man that was a great joke
yeah there you go he got it yeah okay so
I had friends and then they were like
this game's no good the whole game was
preparation you know and he's lucky all
right and then my refutation of their
idiocy was that in this position white
thought for 30 minutes and you guys are
like what does that mean I don't
understand I don't understand that
statement have any of you ever thought
30 minutes on one move now right now
here's what my friends are claiming you
listen over here yeah they said he
already had this all figured out before
the game and he just thought 30 minutes
to remember at all okay
so way he who you've never heard of
because you're like the worst people
ever way he is 16 years old
and he's like number 27 in the world
he's the only player in the world under
the age of 20 in the top 30 or 40 and
he's the champion of China which has
seven players rated 2700 and above I
know it's five or six I'm exaggerating
quiet back there
okay I'm not talking to you about
talking to people at home so way he is
the greatest player ever now I'm not
saying he looks like he's 30 and they're
lying about his age I'm not saying that
okay anyway so way he played 9 to d5 is
it that I good in the center
so yeah right so black is like thinking
of an old 70 song and he says give me
the knife now 99999 of you as Christoph
Waltz would say Christoph Waltz said
nine nine nine percent of the time you'd
be right but 2000 one percent of the
time this is what's happening if you are
white in this position what would you
always play always if you were white in
this position what would you play
it's your white it's your move you
correct man that was painful correct and
so every game in chess history ever
played you just take the knight on d5
that's why this game is special here
why decided there was something better
than taking a knight
what's better than taking a knight
without looking at the board name things
that are better you check reading your
opponent's better than taking a knight
you taking a rock taking a queen the
best is to check me and so white decide
it blacks Kings should go for a walk so
white played the craziest move you've
ever seen rook takes f7 notice white is
threatening checkmate that would be good
for white right now let's go back white
didn't play rook takes f7 last move
because you can't jump over the knight
he's like hey move your knight away from
the air and then I'll take the pawn
yum-yum-yum right so what did black do
about this impending checkmate what it
black do to stop there
what's that louder take the rug and then
black and then white played check now
let's see who's good at counting
probably none of you
how many legal moves does black have how
many ways out of check buckle your shoe
yeah two three what do you think Arjun
how many ways on a check are there three
that's why you went six negative two in
the tournament who went on tiebreaks see
normal this shouldn't be tiebreaks when
it's four out of four let's just give
you both first-place trophy order a
second trophy I'll see what I can do but
since you got the first place trophy who
cares all right so black has three ways
out of check King f8 king of six and
King e6 let's vote let's vote for what
move you think black played who thinks
come on you've been in my class before
us now how you vote who thinks black
played King f8 one person who thinks
black played King f6 one person who
thinks black played King e6 and for once
in my chest career the class is correct
King f8 is very very very risky because
of checkmate so you didn't do that King
f6 is also checkmate but it takes two
moves I mean I see a lot of different
checkmates
I could just take this tonight and I'm
threatening rook F one mate and Queen g6
mate and I'm not good enough to stop
them both is somebody here good enough
to stop them both actually I think I
stopped them both you now he for stops
them both that's what we call a
temporary solution you know what I'm
saying okay so so black play King e6 now
for those of you who showed up late
which is most of you
game was played last week in the in the
tournament in China which has eight very
strong Chinese players a Cuban player
and an Indian player and way he is white
he's the champion of China he's 16 years
old he's top thirty in the world and he
just sacrificed his rook and his knight
if you count the pieces you'll notice
black is ahead of rook and a knight on
the other hand blacks King is a little
suspicious right
okay so pawn takes Knight check now
we're going to vote again first I'll ask
you a question you'll get wrong how many
legal moves does black have I don't like
the answer three because that's correct
one two three no you don't like those
moves now King f6 is risky because white
has rook F 1 checkmate and Queen g6
checkmate
okay so probably he didn't play King f6
although you never know nowadays okay so
you can either play King takes pawn or
Bishop takes pawn
the problem with Bishop takes pawn is
you've trapped your King your King can't
escape so that's that's not so good you
might get checkmated right yeah I don't
see the checkmate as I'm old well I
don't see what to do against Bishop
takes g6 so it's probably Bishop g6
Queen h3 looks good Queen g6 looks good
terrible now do you have an engine over
here because I'm old
was there an engine been oh you're
actually
yeah I've never used the engine but I
know there's like maton 3 here so dude
what am i doing
3 all right and it says Bishop takes g6
is not mate but it's + 4 + 4 is pretty
good now what do I do to get rid of all
that there's no way to do it hey I
believe you see I did believe them so
this move is a winning advantage for
white because White's threatening all
kinds of good stuff it's all good
ok so black played King takes d5 now
you're laughing at blacks King and
rightfully so but black is up a rook so
if black plays King c6 King c7 White's
going to lose for sure White's down a
rook how do you stop black from playing
king c6 and escaping Arjen Bishop efore
check now King c6 is illegal so you
might as well take some more pieces King
takes e4 now this is the most important
part of the game
the part that none of you understand now
you're going to understand it there's
two things you need to do to checkmate
your opponent you need to put them in
check other thing you need to do is to
make sure they can't escape check if you
were black and you wanted to escape
would you go the green way or the red
way the red way you're running away from
White's pieces if black King gets to c6
blacks gonna be up a thousand pieces
you have to stop black from playing King
to d5 you got to stop him from doing
that
Arjen Queen f7 now King here is not so
good
also there are no King moves the king is
trapped on e4 okay so he's in trouble on
the other hand
is up a rook at a bishop on the other
hand White's threatening Queen f3
checkmate and probably there's Bishop
moves that are checked me but I'm too
old to see them black played Bishop to
f6 now my king can escape now if you are
a grandmaster you would play queen d3
checkmate right Arjun Arjun agrees but
none of you are grandmasters so you
can't illegally move your queen however
if you think like a grandmaster then
you'll want to get your Queen over there
now
for all of my advanced students none of
which are here I have a rule always man
the your classmates are like what you
talking about
always make the same mistake twice
you're pretty sure you have to go back
to the drawing board I think how about
never makes the same mistake twice yeah
there you go
ok always repeat ok so white played
Bishop d2 check confusing Bensimon
yeah that's check see black black has
two legal moves but a king f5 don't look
too good
well they don't have one so it's ok
bishop check and white repeated now I
want to play Queen d3 mate
so what move did white play so you could
play Queen d3 mate next move Queen b3
now I'm threatening Queen D 3 million
Queen D three mates good because then
you win yeah let's see how does black
escape Queen d3 mate let's figure this
out King f5 I don't see another move
that stops mate okay rook f1 Shack Black
has three legal moves King here allowing
me that's probably not so good this ship
f3 giving the bishop away that's sin
they play kingi for you now free legal
moves there's an infinite number of
illegal moves okay now white played
Queen ad3 anyway white has two ideas
Queen takes pawn Shack and Queenie to
check and both of them lead to checkmate
now black decided he wanted to check
white White's having too much fun
white keeps attacking the black King
black wants to attack the white king
this should takes G to check and then
Queen a8 check hey he got a couple of
checks in himself
yeah it's check see it's a long check
yeah we did yeah I wouldn't lie to you
Queen a in check I might be teasing but
I'm not okay the King moves out of check
now black has to deal with Queen e2
check and queen g6 check still so he
played Bishop to g5 trade the bishops if
we trade all of the pieces then black
won't get made it who wants to trade
pieces black or white black if the
pieces are all gone then blacks going to
have an extra ruck and blacks King won't
get checkmated so white played check and
black moved his King that makes sense
okay yeah he played King h4 and then he
checked him again check now let's see
what the smartest person in the class is
what it black to in this position
there's only one legal move who can find
it yes why we wouldn't say h3 you would
say King edge three right now this looks
more like a bughouse game in a real game
looks like a bughouse game okay now
white play the finishing touch which
ended the game a very unusual move so
sometimes in chess
No sometimes in chess your pieces block
your other pieces for example in the
starting position of chess your pawns
are blocking your king your Queen your
bishops and your rooks you can't move
those pieces because all your pawns are
in the way if you took all of your pawns
off when the game starts you could move
all of your pieces but those pawns are
blocking all of your pieces except the
knight the Argent make more noise please
thank you
perfect all right good job no you did
good
that gives Bensimon some editing to do
all right so in this position white has
one piece that blocks two of his pieces
it's his bishop it's blocking his rook
and it's blocking his Queen if that
bishop wasn't there white could make all
these moves but he can't do because the
bishops blocking that guy's correct you
feeling all right that's right this
should be one as I like to say always
retreat okay
now White has a threat because his
bishop got out of the way I'm going to
make a dumb move for black to show you
White's threat that's a dumb move
White's threatening rook f3 check if you
take it that's checkmate if you don't
take it you'll go here and I'll go check
and I'll go check and I'll go checkmate
okay so I'm threatening rook f3 check
and that leads to checkmate how does
black stop rook f3 well there's two ways
to do it
rook f8 that protects f3 then we trade
rooks and then checkmate the reason
don't do that the reason Queen g2 wasn't
check made earlier is because this Queen
was defending g2 so if you play Queen g2
oh well if you play queen g2 and say
check me your opponent will play queen
g2 and say checkmate okay so you can do
that all right now the other way to stop
rook f3 check is with the pawn the is
with the pawn now the pawn stops rook f3
but it blocks the Queen
so now checkmate again so White's
threatening rook f3 with checkmate quiet
please
and there's no way to stop it so now
black did something you've never done
before
he gave up because he knows he's getting
checkmated so before you got checkmated
he gave up according to the chess engine
Bishop II ones the only winning move
there is no other move there wins and
it's really winning it doesn't announce
me that says like +25 okay black gives
all his pieces away to stop mate not
good okay so that was something you
don't see very often a grandmaster level
black moving his King around okay and
getting checkmated and the reason it
wasn't so one-sided it was close is
because white kept giving all his pieces
away that's something I talked about in
the last class which you weren't at
chess is easy if you do all things that
are good and your opponent does all
things that are bad then you win but
sometimes in chess you have to do
something bad so your opponent does
something worse and sometimes your
judgement is wrong you're like oh yeah I
lost a rook but I have a mating attack
then you don't checkmate the guy then
you're down a rook then you're like darn
where's my rook in this game white give
a lot of pieces away and he knew or he
thought or he figured out or he guessed
he was going to checkmate the black King
and he turned out to be right did he
figure it all out 20 moves ago we don't
know okay he used his judgment he's like
yeah your King shouldn't walk up the
board eventually I'll check me at him
and he was right and black said a free
rook free Knight free bishop okay so
both sides were happy and now only
whites happy and that game is
because at the Grand Master level it's
very rare to give all of your pieces
away and eventually checkmate your
opponent that's usually reserved for
tactical puzzles you go on the internet
chess
kid calm chess comm what's the other
place called chest tempo you open a book
that has puzzles and you see things like
this somebody invented them
exactly but this was an actual game and
this game was played a few days ago and
I was watching it live and I was like
wow that King's running around that was
interesting now I had a game like this
in 1992 that's probably right against
the Dutch player champion de Boer I
spits I said it right and he's a Dutch
player and de Boer as you know names
means farmer I'm sure you kids are all
familiar with the Boer Wars right yeah
Alec Lee said yeah that's good and de
Boer was their national master I
sacrificed my rook in the middle game
and his King ran all over the board and
eventually I won 20 moves later and
actually won a lot of money for that
game they gave me a brilliancy prize but
that was play when I was young like wait
ye not that young okay I think I was 20
no I was 22 yeah I was 22 okay so when I
was younger I'd sacrifice my rook and
the opponent's king went all over the
board and I'd win now that I'm old I can
show you games other people did it right
and this game just happened a few days
ago that's one good thing about the
Internet you can watch games live you
can watch them as they're happening and
then you can see crazy people make crazy
comments about them one day you'll be
that crazy person
you